hey everyone welcome back to another
recap video
uh from my national open tournament in
vegas
it's been a few weeks since the
tournament has finished and i've still
been kind of reflecting on my games
doing some analysis and in this video i
want to share two games
and i actually played in back-to-back
rounds
brother and then sister one of the best
brother-sister duos in the country
derek wu and rochelle wu both national
masters
both a little bit low rated than me but
still tough opponents
and now we'll focus on this first game
against derek
and this is a name that you might
recognize he is
a streamer on twitch and
he made a pretty notable appearance in
one of my most popular
youtube uploads ever video
everyone falls for this new opening trap
he was actually the person who
led me on to this england gambit bishop
c5 trap
if i just play a brief moment yeah this
guy
um let's do this
fall for it
so anyway um i knew he's a uh
very active online blitzen bullet player
uh one of the founding fathers of this
england gambit trap
um so i i do owe him a lot of credit for
uh
being one of the first people to
discover that trap and
i had the black pieces against him and
he played
d4 on move one now before the game
i didn't really have much time to
prepare but
i knew i wasn't going to play any
dubious gambit especially england gabit
if i play this against him uh
it's just too much of a risk in
classical chess
and i would have very quickly gone a uh
just worse position
so i stuck with my my main repertoire
played a
queen's gambit declined and
i managed to surprise him relatively
early as early as move
4 i played pawn a6 which is a move i
don't think i've ever played before
in tournament chess but i've played
similar ideas sometimes i play a6
later on i have a decent number of games
after
bishop e7 bishop g5 castle e3 and then
a6
but the point of playing a6 in these
sort of structures
is to prepare pawn takes pawn
and then the ventral b5 bishop b7 c5 and
get the early expansion
on the queen side and this is something
that's been trendy
in recent years even at the highest
levels magnus carlsen has been known for
playing this move
um in this position also in positions
uh like this um a6 is
is becoming more acceptable these days
so
when i played a6 in the game derek uh
took a
somewhat of a think and then played pawn
to c5
which normally isn't that great like in
queen's gambit usually you should leave
the tension but because i played a6
white is trying to punish me as much as
possible
also preventing me from taking and
playing b5 and getting a nice open
position
so i went ahead i played b6 which
is kind of the thematic move and
i should note here that it's not great
for white to play b4
even though this looks pretty consistent
with the plans because after a5
the the pawns are kind of falling apart
white can't fly a3 because takes and
there's a pin
and if takes on b6 i would take on b4
and black is just getting the upper hand
here
so here my opponent took on b6
and this is where i think i made one of
my biggest mistakes
of the game surprisingly enough
i went ahead i just automatically
recaptured without almost any thought
because i
thought this was my only logical move
and then after the game was actually
derek who told me
that i have another option here
that didn't even cross my mind so i'll
pose this as an exercise
for viewers black to move what's the
other
candidate move apart from pawn takes
pawn
feel free to pause the video if you
can't can't immediately see it
but the move i should have considered
and if i did consider it i probably
would have played it
is pawn c5 which is actually a pretty
stylish move
first of all white can't on passant i
know maybe some people are just learning
the rules of montpessant
um you can only on passant when there's
a pawn on the fifth rank
uh not on the sixth rank so if you're
still confused you can google it
but the benefit of pawn c5 is that
i want to recapture with the queen and i
want to pressure
the center and essentially i just want
to trade off
c-pawn for d-pawn and get a situation
where let's say we trade i'll take back
and i'll have two center pawns against
one center pawn
um now white would have different ways
of responding to this
and if we look at the database there's
been
yeah there haven't been too many games
in master level play just one
according to leech us but uh we look at
the leachate database box scores pretty
well
from this line and it would have been a
nice way to make the position a bit more
open a bit more dynamic
uh what happened in the game is i took
back
and we got a much more symmetrical
pawn structure which
made it very very difficult for me to
create like any dynamic play
now i felt bad after the game when i
realized
i could have played c5 but then right
before i started recording this video
i actually found a game from
magnus carlson that was played a few
months ago
he played the same opening against rajab
i believe this was back in april
maybe some kind of chess 24 event and
they went into the same line and magnus
also took back on v6
so i guess i can't be too disappointed
if i played the same move as magnus
but given the the situation in the game
i was a couple hundred points higher
rated
i really should have tried to make
things more dynamic
and as we're going to see with uh simple
development
from from both sides um
it was hard for black to really create
much in the position i had a slightly
worse bishop
on b7 and pawns are
almost completely symmetrical so
i went with the the only plan i could
think of is to expand
on the queen side with pawn b5 and
there's a few ideas with this move
one is to maneuver the knight to c4
another idea is to eventually play b4
and then a5 and then bishop a6
so very positional play i'm looking to
kind of grab space
and make gradual improvements
but my opponent played very solidly
starting with bishop b1
knight b6 95 knight c4
and i got my outpost i was looking
forward to a situation where if white
takes
i would take back and i have a nice open
bishop nice pawn chain
but then why play knight d3
and it looks like a weird setup
but the knight's relatively well placed
on d3
and white wants to give me a taste of my
own medicine
with some idea of knight c5
so i played knight g7 um just
controlling c5
b3 was played and
yeah this is unfortunate part about my
knight being on c4 is it's not
technically an outpost uh but the
benefit after b3
i was able to play knight a3 and get rid
of
white's bishop knight f4 takes b1
takes and i play a5 so i was really
trying to
to create some imbalance man should get
bishop for night um but it's not a huge
type of thing to play for
and what ended up happening in the game
honestly wasn't too
invigorating we uh we traded all the
the rooks and then
eventually we traded the queens um just
because this was only open file
in order to fight for the file i had to
initiate trades
and then we got to this position which
on the surface it looks completely
completely equal
very close to josh i was optimistic
that i would have some chances to play
for uh for a win just because these
pawns are
fixed on light squares
and in my wildest fantasies i was
envisioning
getting the bishop to b1 winning all the
pawns and making a queen
unfortunately that's very hard to do
when the knights are
kind of covering the key squares next
three moves were a matter
of improving for both sides um 91
brought my king in and
here the night uh yeah the knight found
a nice outpost
um and this was another key moment
in the game i think this was the second
like really
big mistake that i made if you look at
this this game with engine
it will say that very very few
mistakes were made i don't think any
blunders were made but
um my next move
was uh was incorrect and i'll pose this
as another exercise for viewers
i'm going to give two options here only
two two candidate moves to consider here
is bishop coming back to c8 or
bishop e5 these should really be the
main choices
some of you might think bishop e2 is
also a choice but this would just run
into f3 and then the king will come in
and the bishop doesn't want to go in too
far to white's territory
so between bishop b5 and bishop c8s
i chose the wrong option
i played bishop e5 which during the time
i thought this was the most logical of
course i keep the
control of this diagonal i still want to
have potential
for playing bishop d3 at some point when
the knights are not here
the flaw in my thought process
was i didn't fully acknowledge
my long-term plan and realize how white
can counter that plan
of course i i wanted to execute a plan
of king d6 f6
and e5 which i thought would be a nice
way to
try and destabilize white setup
in the center the problem with this plan
is that there's a very pesky knight to
b7 check
whenever my king goes to d6 and
we're going to see how this plays out
but
to make this easier to understand i
should have played bishop
to c8 even though this looks really
passive this would have restricted the
knight
and then allowed me to play this this
and this
and it would have offered better winning
chances
um as we see what happens in the game
okay f4 is played
fine move i still carry through with um
yeah immediately e5 white takes
takes knight c2 i play king
d6 and um
i have a thread here i'm threatening to
take on
d4 and then take a gun on d4 so if white
wastes a move
i can take take take and i
believe this is winning a pawn because
after takes takes
i'm just up upon and knight b7 i can
move here to defend
um maybe it'd still be tricky but this
should be winning for that because after
takes takes takes
my king will come in this pawn is passed
these pawns are
very very weak so
unfortunately white has a move here
white doesn't have to waste time with
playing h3
derek pretty quickly played knight b7
i played king c7 and then
he repeated and i realized
i'm just not better here i really want
to bring my king in
my other pieces are basically fully
optimized i didn't see a way to play on
for a win
so i just repeated and the game ended in
a draw
and um i was slightly disappointed
afterwards because i felt like
i didn't create enough winning chances
for myself
but kudos to derek for playing a
relatively mistake-free
and clean game okay let's move on
to the next game it was the following
day i played
derek's sister rochelle wu who i have
had a history with we played once before
in 2019 and i have
i have video proof of it uh we played in
st
louis at the 2019 norm congress
um and we had a super super long game
where
she was absolutely crushing me but
somehow i
miraculously survived an endgame
down two pawns i'll leave a link in this
uh in the video description in case
people want to watch this coverage
there's commentary from ben simon and
gm alexander lenderman but in vegas
the situation was different i managed to
avoid getting a losing position
and oh i do have a story
before we actually get into the game as
i arrive for the game
i think i arrived like a couple minutes
late
and as i was finding the board
rochelle was already had already sat
down and was trying to figure out
how to set her chest clock and she
didn't know how to
i didn't know how to set her clock so i
just decided
we just decided to use my clock so i
quickly set it and put it next to the
board
and then i started like writing on my
score sheet before we actually started
the game
and she gave me this like weird look
when i looked up
i realized that when i set the clock
down
her time was running and i hadn't made a
move yet
so yeah usually you should not have your
time running when you're black
and white hasn't made a move and she
looked at me
and she said i think it's your move
and uh and i realized what was going on
and i just reset the clock
but it was a very polite way to to
handle that situation
um so anyway we started the game um
she ended up starting my clock and i
played e4
and one of the reasons why i arrived a
couple minutes late
is because i spent trying to spend as
much time as possible
preparing for her repertoire
and i i knew to look up her previous
tournament games
and her online games and i knew that
she's
a uh pretty loyal night or player
likes to play night or and not too much
else
so i was expecting this position and
i knew she had one game from a few
months ago
in the variation after pawn d4
and this is a relatively trendy line
especially at the highest level play
like if you look this up in masters
database
you'll see caruana mvl carlson
i believe this position was played in
the candidates
uh between grishok and mvl as far as i
know this doesn't have an official name
leech just calls this a closed sicilian
i believe carlson was one of the earlier
innovators of this variation
and at first it doesn't seem too logical
because after takes takes
it seems like black can just play knight
c6 and white is wasting time
with the queen but the point of playing
this is to go for a setup with queen d2
b3 bishop b2 castling and then
expand on the the king side with either
f4 or f3 and g4
and we got something very similar in the
game
uh instead of knight c6 she played a6 uh
perhaps
just preventing bishop to b5
i continue b3 now knight c6
drop back and she was taking time on
every move
so in the opening i was feeling pretty
comfortable
about the position i played bishop b2
bishop g7 and castling so
up until this point i didn't really need
to use so much time
and at this point when i castled
she was away from the board i think
maybe she was checking out other games
or maybe getting water
and then a photographer came by
the event had a photographer taking
taking pictures of all the top boards
so the photographer came like across
from me
and i wasn't sure whether to
[Music]
pose for the camera or just try and look
candid
but then the photo was posted
on facebook and i decided to try and
smile for the camera
um but this photo i was just smiling
with my eyes
um so you can see the position here
you can see the clock is set to black to
move
and uh i was trying to
to look into the the camera's soul
um anyway if people want to see more
photos from this event i'll leave the
link to the
the facebook album in the video
description so
eventually she got back photographer
walked away
and the game continued she played bishop
d7
and in my preparation for this game
i didn't look at this specific position
i just looked at ideas
i saw a lot of like high level games or
like it was for this attack
especially against the feet and kettle
setup but i started thinking in this
position
because i realized there's a kind of a
cool option
that i can play given that black is a
little bit slow
to develop hasn't played knight f6 yet
and i went ahead and played knight to d5
which is a very ambitious move
but the point is to slow down black's
development
it's now no longer good for black to
play knight f6 because i can take
and eventually black will either have to
take pawn or after takes takes takes
i'll win the d6 pawn
so after knight d5 she took on b2
i take back and now we get a situation
where this knight
is still having trouble developing black
doesn't necessarily want to play e6
because it's weakening
to d6 so
i was feeling happy um she played rook
c8 i think this is a very
reasonable move and here i went ahead
and played h4
going for the immediate flank pawn
attack
it's especially effective against the
structure and if black does allow me to
play h5
it can cause serious problems especially
with
the king still in the center and for
that reason black
played h5 just preventing me from
from expanding and here i played queen
c3
so trying to keep initiative hitting the
rook and
attempting to force black to make some
sort of concession
and there's not too many ways for black
to
deal with this a move like rook h7
doesn't make much sense
a rook is ridiculous here would allow
for ideas of eventually knight g5
and a move like 95 even though this
looks
nice it blocks the attack it hits a
queen
i can respond with queen d4
targeting b6 and also threatening f4
to attack the the now pinned knight
so for this reason she played pawn e5
which is probably the best move in the
position
even though it does make a kind of big
concession as it leaves this pawn
very backwards also weakens the d5
square
because now there's no black pawn that
can
move to e6 to get rid of my knight
so game continues i play queen e3 idea
of targeting b6 and now
oh she plays knight f6 challenging my
knight and i realized that
this move is actually a plunder now
if i go for knight b6 looks nice
attacking the rook also attacking the
pawn
black would have a nice response knight
g4
counter-attacked my queen and there'd be
no way to move my queen to still
save my knight so instead of
over-extending with my knight i develop
another piece
bishop c4 reinforcing the knight
and here she played b5 which i was kind
of expecting
now during the game i was a little bit
more concerned about knight g4
still idea being i would have to retreat
with my queen
and then b5 and then i would have to
retreat with my bishop
um however after a move like bishop f1
i'd still have
good control over the position um in the
game
with the media b5 i didn't have to
retreat my bishop
i was able to take on f6 and after queen
f6
plant my bishop on d5 and
we reach a very typical kind of sicilian
structure
uh structure with g6 e5 and e4
where i have very nice control over d5
and it's really up to black to try and
create some counter play in the position
which is not easy to do
given that i have some nice central
control
so she plays knight b4 hitting my bishop
and my pawn
more importantly my pawn so i play c3
takes now i take with rook very
important to keep
the d file half open taking with pawn
would solve black's problems
and uh when i take with rook this pawn
is still
a major major weakness in the position
so she castles i play knight f3
and i was feeling very good here because
the play
just continues to flow very naturally
i'm ready to play
rook d1 potentially triple up and then
just try and win
the d-pawn and it's really up to black
to figure out either how to defend the
d-pawn
or try and generate counter play and she
went ahead and actually
played one of the best moves in the
position
bishop to g4 going after my knights
also freeing up potential for rook d8 to
defend the pawn
and here i went ahead and played queen
g5
which is one of the most forcing moves
in the position
um simply trying to trade queens it's
very typical whenever you have a
just a better structure than your
opponent and your opponent has clear
weaknesses in this case
pawn on d6 then the more trades that
happen
the more glaring the weakness becomes
and
i realized we would get into an end game
situation
where very very likely this pawn would
fall
so black doesn't have too many options
here if she plays queen e6
i can play knight h2 a very strong move
exploiting the bishop threatening to
trap the bishop with f3
so she went ahead she took i took
and during the game i thought i was
doing really well here given that uh
ready to win the pawn or potentially
reinforce with rook
to d1 however
after the game i analyze this with
engine and
to my surprise stockfish prefers black
here
after a line which i did calculate in
the game but i didn't evaluate correctly
uh black can take on f3 takes and then
play rook c6
and during the game i thought okay i can
play rook d1 i'm guaranteed to win a
pawn
because of rook d8 i thought i could
take on e5
um this was an incorrect assessment
because if i take
black can play rook dc8
and then all of a sudden my c3 pawn is
hit
and my rook is hit and black is uh is
the one playing for a win
on top of that but i could even play a
move like king g7 here
and if i go and win the pawn black gets
a lot of counter play with pawn h4
now i should know i can't take on a6
because there's a nice move rook d8
preventing my rook from coming back and
this pawn is guaranteed
pretty much to promote so after h4
white can move back with rook d1 but
then
f6 and black is very quick to
activate on the king's side after takes
takes the king is ready to come in it's
very typical
especially in rook pawn and games
that material doesn't always tell the
whole story
and sometimes it's not about how many
pawns you have
it's about how dangerous the past
pawns are in the position this position
black has only past pawn
which is going to be supported by the
king and the rook
i have some palm witnesses and i'm a bit
slow to
generate counter play on the queen side
so this is a big missed opportunity for
her
but it's hard to blame her like i i
thought this position would be better
for me but
it was a type of thing which was hard to
evaluate from
a distance so in the game
um she played a move which was an
attempt to make things really
complicated
pawn to f5 unfortunately for her it
backfired then i was able to get a
really nice position
now my next move i do have to apologize
for
because i know there's a certain
community online
that is very very passionate about
on passant and will get very triggered
whenever i have a chance to on passant
and don't do it this is one of those
positions where on poissant
is just not a good move um
even though it's possible
pawn takes pawn rook takes pawn
this would solve all of black's problems
it would defend this give
black counter play it's not a move
that is good and
i i was clearly aware of that and
despite the moral dilemma i
i managed to find the the actual best
move in the position
knight to d2 and this is a very nice
positional move
because i threaten to play pawn f3 again
to trap the bishop
and i also reinforce e4 pawn
meanwhile still attacking d6
and after takes takes i found myself
with
an amazingly placed knight my night
covers
all of my pawn weaknesses while also
attacking
black's weakness on d6 also potential
for knight f6
where i would get a very very nice
outpost it would be very hard for black
to remove the knight
without sacrificing material so
going forward from this position i um
eventually won the pawn play f3 first
win the pawn on d6
and after takes takes rook
to d8 uh she tried to get counter play
along the d
file but i willingly walked into
the pin played rook d1 supporting my
knight
and with this move i i knew that my plan
is to play rook t2
and then knight e4 to neutralize the
d-file
this is what happened king f8 rook d2
king e7 and 94. and here i was offering
the work trade
if she does decide to take i would
happily take back
and then go for the
expansion on the queen side and put the
knight back on on e4
and white is uh very close to just
easily winning from here
so she avoided the rook trade played
rook to c8
and then unfortunately for black things
got very very passive
i invaded she defended
i invaded some more uh she defended some
more
and we got a situation where it was full
domination
these pieces are tied down very sadly to
the asics pawn um but i do have to give
her kudos cause i thought during the
game
that i would win by resignation and
probably just a few more moves
but she really fought on and tried to
stay alive and
keep every ounce of hope alive
so it did take work i played knight to
d3
going after this pawn which can't be
defended
she developed the bishop again i take
king g7 uh i threw in the check rook b7
king f8 and then i play g4
some attempt to simplify on the king
side
and make use of my three-on-two majority
then she played the move uh to try and
confuse me
a rook e8 counter-attacking my knights
um the nice thing for me i'm up two
pawns so i'm
happy with trades i take takes
take take on g5 and even though this
pawn
looks like a goner i'm able to counter
attack with rook
h7 i should note here that g7
may look attractive to some people to
try and initiate the rook trade
if i did go for rook train i would be
losing here because this pawn is
uncatchable
um so i have to be careful when the
opponent has
an outside passer but
yeah i keep my rook keep an eye on the h
pawn
she plays king g8 and then
i slowly but surely make progress
on the queen side it's very hard for
black to do
anything so active so
i tried to be patient we traded pawns
and then i brought my rook around going
for rookie six
uh she played the right move rook f6
guaranteeing to win the g
pawn and i'm actually not winning a pawn
but because i have a three on two
and their king is so far away from the
queen side
it was a pretty routine win and the way
i managed to win this
is by making a pasty pawn and
making sure that her king
does not get back to uh to the queen
side
so um yeah so i keep the king cut off
and then we entered what is actually a
pretty well
known type of end game uh known as the
lucina position
now lucino usually is a position where
there's just one pawn in rook versus
rook
in this case there's the two extra pawns
but i use very
very typical lucina ideas of keeping the
king cut off
and working my way up with my pawn and
my king
and there's not much black can do to
actually
stop my my pawn advance with the rook
uh she gives a check i move up i start
pushing
push some more and then
i get my pawn to the seventh rank now
one of the key things with
knowing how to convert the lucina
position is knowing how to
actually promote the pawn because if i
move to either side
the rook will check if i move too far
away the rook will come back
and keep an eye from behind so
there's a few ways to win this position
the way i was taught when i was a kid
is to build the so-called bridge is to
play rook
to e4 and it's called a bridge because
we have to make shelter for our king
and the rook is going to provide shelter
now for those who haven't seen this
before it may not seem so obvious at
first
why why i put my rook here but the point
is that after
okay she plays a waiting move now i move
my king threaten to promote
check here check here
and if she delivers another check i can
play king
c5 and after this check
my rook is perfectly placed to block and
her king is just too far away to stop
the pawn
and this is the so-called bridge where
the rook is sheltering my king
from uh from this check and be an easy
win from here
so in the game she actually didn't let
me build the bridge
she played king f5 attacking my rook
but now i just moved to e8 threatening
to queen
if she checks i would i would actually
find shelter behind the apon
and uh yeah queen is queening is
guaranteed
and because of this she resigned after
rookie yates
so overall i'm happy with the game i
think it was pretty clean there were
maybe a couple hiccups in the middle
game
but always lessons to take away and i am
happy that i got to play this kind of
cool
surprise opening that worked out pretty
well
so uh hope you guys enjoyed the the two
games against uh
the wu siblings uh stay tuned for
more recaps again if you have any
questions
feel free to leave them in the comments
and if you want to analyze on your own
i'll leave a link
to the study in the video description
but for now
so long and i'll see you in the next
video